right good afternoon everyone uh welcome
to this uh extraordinary meeting of uh
cabinet
so without any further ado we'll start
on the agenda
i have it's on
uh apologies for absence and
thank you on disclosures of interest are
there any disclosures of interest
i'll take that as a no
in that case we move on to climate
change portfolio revised arrangements
for processing of domestic dry recycling
council shenton
thank you leader i don't propose to go
into any great detail
on this at this point but withdraw
attention just to two sections of the
paper
so section 1.8 sets out the agreement
reached with biffa
and in my opinion presents a pragmatic
view and a sensible course of action in
the circumstances
section 2 spells out the options very
clearly with section 2.3
setting out the implications of not
approving the agreement
at this agreement and as you can see the
start reality is that the statutory
service could be impacted to the
detriment of our residents and as it
states
the expense might yet be recovered
so
i would ask therefore that the
recommendation contained on page one
is accepted
thank you leader thank you councillor
shenton you've proposed the
recommendations on page one does anyone
have any questions
counselor kettle
i think just for the record we know that
biffa were our prior suppliers or waste
handlers
uh did we speak to any other parties
uh other than before about this
sorry i should have switched my mic up
and still get it on
and
speak to other parties about
the possibility
what we did with the what we did on the
uh the waste was
if you remember we
initially it was going to edmonton in
london two-thirds there one-third to
worcester
um going with biffa represents uh if you
like security
of where we can dispose and it goes to
their site
in london and looking to germany that's
their site isn't the new one um and
this represents the best option there
are very few places that can take our
commingled waste and even and even fewer
than that there are very few murphs that
are actually uh not fully um operational
if you like and have capacity so we
don't really have that many options this
was the best option to
go thank you thank you thank you that
seemed to be clear councillor barker um
can i second the proposal please of
course you can councillor barker
uh in that case
sorry we've had a proposal and the
second uh the recommendations
penny anne sorry
don't worry don't worry it's just a
quick comment um on behalf of osc first
of all thank you very much for taking
the time um around briefing um around
this and we can see you know it's a very
thorough piece of work and these were
unprecedented circumstances we were just
saying because it's actually been
handled so efficiently be very useful
much further down the line to just have
a report back about strategies used
because i do think that julie and her
team have absolutely moved mountains to
make sure that our residents were not
without the service for a protracted
period of time um so just i think it's
not it's good to have a positive
story when something like this happens
and i'd be good just to reflect back
with councillor shanton and julian her
team about less than positive lessons
learnt and advice you know to make
hopefully we'll be one of the few
authorities this has happened in but we
may not be the only one
thank you council o'donnell i think
you're absolutely right the fact that we
got the
service up and running rapidly i think
was a tribute to
all the staff involved i think it was
really good and the fact that we've got
a resolution for this i think is good we
now have a proposal and a second uh so
members of kevin sorry
so i'd just like to pass on uh my thanks
to to julian i'm sure we'll
all agree here she's done a tremendous
job here
i think we all appreciate that
so
for the third time of asking we have a
proposer and the second members of
cabinet
are you willing to support the
recommendations one to three on page one
agreed thank you members of cabinet
urgent business i have none
so i then declare the meeting closed